I don't have to tell you what that means
you shouldn't be on the internet if you
don't know what that means
take your internet vibe pass away hello
I'm Maggie from the 1975 and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
it's actually me this is actually me
twister there we go
honestly how does Maggie he did not get
whiplash during every concert easier
without a mom when it's like this it
doesn't you don't feel it identity
crisis
yeah having long hair can be a lot of
maintenance how does Matty Healy find
the time to be happy when he's
constantly singing songs that mean so
much sad emotions good question I think
this destination the wick holder which
is so important I think that happiness
is great and it's nice in yeah it's good
to have moments of happiness enjoy and
do the constant pursuit of happiness
teaches us that when you're not happy
you're wrong I wonder if Truman black
write songs like Kerouac books you know
Hemingway write drunk edit sober Kerouac
write drunk never read it that's a nice
tweet unfortunately I'm not as deaf
identity
neither anyway both Kerouac I've tried I
think that there's a lot of mystique and
the myth in creation and I think that
I'm more interested in kind of a
scientific analysis of why we feel these
ways the way that I write is kind of
like hardly very fluid and important
sort out you know I'm never nailing the
Benzedrine on a typewriter which would
be dope I'm in love with everything
you've released for music for cars so
far but I have one question will the top
of the ninth 75 be releasing anything
more in the vein of old music for cars
in the knee
future that's cool if you don't - I love
hearing your progression so the question
is will we were releasing music in the
vein of what music for cars was on the
EPS
I mean I think that's kind of a bit like
the record now it's kind of what we were
going for a bit
I mean we've kind of like started up our
old old band manic by the way that's in
the core internet question for Mike
Healy the 9:35 has never really been a
political band what made you guys decide
to broker the subject kind of related
follow up I was at your last MSG show
and it's 85% females
why is that and is it okay to be a male
fan okay that's a lot of questions first
question about being political I don't
even know if we are that political but I
know it's a hard question that we're in
a time and we're in a context and I
suppose like if you well okay you say we
never used to be I think that we used to
be quite inward but the English
perspectives for anyone I think you grow
into at least narrow I really admire did
and I suppose I aspire to be as great as
them and why is it mainly women are
shows I mean
85% is a very specific statistic so
you've been doing your homework but I
think it's it's fine to be a male fine
bro it's cool don't worry you'll be all
right good plays how is the 1975
creating global climate change awareness
well I don't know it'll change now and
the pandemic I've gotten rid of my
shower to have a live show anymore all
of my big screens and wake up and all
that stuff that's all gone so I'm
inventing a new show I mean I don't even
you know I've got word that to a new
world well what we were doing was
planting a tree for every ticket sold
we're trying to make a discount on a new
tool we have educational facilities at
the front of my shows who could teach
you about your recycling there was lots
of things that we did but the important
thing is is that there's lots of things
that you can do what genre of music is
the main
yes what's your favorite their 1975
lyric there's no new record that says I
won't get clothes online because I get
worried about this can you compare the
yeah I mean I'm not gonna cloud chase
the beagles you're alright I'll move on
to ready ready okay is bringing us the
true or false the 1975 this is like a
headline from Dexter weapon the 1975's
mighty Healy play face onstage at Green
Day age 13 that's true as a true story I
was a when he years later exactly tree
we were all very drunken at the hotel in
Hollywood they weren't listening but it
is a nice full circle moment for me at
least
Wikipedia do I even have a Wikipedia
I've know I looked up Wikipedia since
take the first album of a there's some
chaos on there they passed their early
days covering punk songs in a local club
Ely was originally the drummer but took
over vocals after the previous thing I
left to start another band yeah it's
pretty much true hang was going out with
a girl that was in my form so she came
over to me and said my boyfriend wants
to start a band he knows that you play
drums so I was like okay go and tell him
to talk to me that's been a whole
defining thing of what hangs like anyway
but that's another story and then we all
met up and I was the drummer and I was
singing and then we had this singer
called Elliott who was in a band called
airship and his band was kind of pretty
cool at the time so he did one rehearsal
doesn't he thought this bunch of bugs so
he left and he went and joined editors
in the end he's in the band editors now
I was still very very close friends but
yeah I was originally a drummer but then
I met George and changed my life so
we're on to YouTube
anyone here the subtle Third Eye Blind
the semi charm semi charm is he's put
semi charged life but it's semi charmed
kind of reference in the guitar he's
talking about I mean that song is just
like it's way more like I love like I
love look like this myself
what does this mean do they mean that
what does that mean oh well that's
happening on the coat I don't have to
tell you what that means you shouldn't
be on the internet if you don't know
what that means I take your internet
vibe pass away what do you mean what
does it mean there's no meaning in it
it's a photo two legs it's like my legs
come on don't do that right who's the
next one Mattie should I get mad Ernie
is failed this or love it if we made it
tattooed like modernity has failed us
there you go there's an actual answer I
don't know you do what you want both
next for where can I get those boots
though Camden surely I mean no just
Camden but new rocks they're just
they're just like the shoes of the
cybergoth I think I remember seeing
people wear them all my life so they
shouldn't be too hard to find that guy
one two three four is that is your real
name I'm very much down okay I have
finished I hope that was enlightening
goodbye